-Our next guest is
a Tony-nominated actor
you know from shows like
"Spin City," "Mad About You,"
and "Curb Your Enthusiasm," as
well as the movie "Inside Out."
He stars in "East New York,"
which airs Sunday nights
on CBS
and streams on Paramount Plus.
Let's take a look.
-I believe in what you're doing.
I understand why
you're doing it.
I'm just afraid that the forces
arrayed against you
may be overwhelming.
-I expect to have the support
of Chief Suarez.
If it's politically advangeous,
I expect to have the support
of Deputy Mayor Sharpe.
I also just might
have the support of the people
who live in East New York.
-And you have me.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
the one, the only Richard Kind!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Let's get rid of this, 'cause
I want to just talk to you
and not worry about
anybody who's calling.
I just want to talk to you.
-Okay, thank you.
-'Cause we're on TV.
-You do use the compass app,
though.
-All the time!
And Google Maps all the time.
You get out of a subway,
you don't know which way
you're going.
Where's Sullivan Street?
Is it north?
[ Applause ]
Thank you!
I'm a man of the people.
-Oh, boy.
Right off the bat. Right off
the bat with the pander.
Congratulations!
You have played so many
different roles
over your career, and here you
are as a police officer.
-I'm a cop.
-Wow.
-I'm a New York cop.
-Look at you.
-It's unbelievable,
and when I got hired --
my resume is, like you said,
"Inside Out" and "Curb"
and comedies,
and then look at what
I look like.
-Yeah.
-And I walk down the street
and I see some of the
New York cops
with stomachs here and I go,
"Ahh, I could be a cop."
-Yeah.
-Ehh, I could be a cop.
And so I'm a cop. I'm a cop!
-Do you like it?
-Oh, I love it.
Well, first of all,
why do I like it?
Because I don't have to
hold for laughs.
I like that.
I found out -- I was on
"Finding Your Roots,"
which the show on PBS
with Henry Louis Gates.
And I found out that
my great-grandfather
was killed, was murdered.
He and the nephew,
and you take a look at him --
and this is something
I never knew --
he could have been a gangster.
-Really?
-What happened between
him and me?
[ Laughter ]
Why aren't I tough?
Why am I not a tough guy?
-Well, it didn't seem like
it worked out great for him.
-No, but let's hope
he deserved it.
-Yeah, well, you know what?
That's a good way of
looking at it.
-Yeah, I mean, he got murdered.
My grandfather was,
they called him an athlete
because he had his nose broken
11 times.
He was a boxer.
-This is your grandfather?
-My grandfather, Alvin.
What happened between
him and me?
He was a tough guy.
11 times his nose was broken.
I was in a bike accident with
my friend, Bruce Stern,
when I was in first grade.
I fell on the sidewalk.
I broke my nose.
That's all I got for it.
-Really?
-That's the toughest I've been.
-And you haven't been on
a bike since.
-Yeah, right. No. I have.
But you know what was weird
that night?
Because you stay up late,
everything broken.
I watched "The Untouchables"
that night,
and Al Capone,
at the end of the show --
you know, the bad guy
always loses.
-Yeah.
-It was a two-parter.
But I don't know two-parters.
I'd never seen an hour show,
much less "The Untouchables."
Al Capone won.
To this day, I'm terrified.
-Wow!
-I was so scared
when I was a kid.
-Because you were a first
grader.
You'd taken a bad fall
on the bike,
and then you find out
the bad guy wins.
-And you find out
the bad guys win.
Eh, let's not talk about that.
-I'm glad you managed to
work through that trauma.
I want to ask,
and then we're gonna take
a quick commercial break,
but you've been in over
300 things.
We looked at your list
of credits.
I would imagine there's a wide
breadth of people who come up
to you and recognize you from
different shows and films.
-They do.
If they're on the
East or West Coast,
they come up for "Curb."
If they're Jewish, it's a show
called "A Serious Man."
If they're of a certain age,
it's "Mad About You."
The weird thing is "Big Mouth,"
you know.
[ Cheers ]
Yes.
-For the kids.
-But it's also the people who
don't know me but do know me,
and they come up --
I had one last night --
I had one that's great
that came up last night.
A guy goes, "Oh, dude!
The last time I saw you
was at Ringo Starr's 70th
birthday party
at the Capitol Records
building."
[ Laughter ]
No. No.
So he didn't know who I was.
But the best, this is the best.
"Oh, I don't --
Oh, yeah, I know!
You used to run the porn stand
over on 34th Street."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now, Richard,
were you around there enough
that people thought you
maybe ran it?
[ Laughter ]
-So it matters where they're
from, what age they're from.
Then they know. But I can't...
-You've got a lot of
other projects coming out.
We're gonna talk abut them
real quick.
We'll be right back
with Richard Kind.